[Music]
you're after something
is it revenge
money
[Music]
or is it something else you look good
little rough around the edges but good
heard about a job big shot gangster
putting together crew
I'm a driver and I'm a flier
the waited a long time for a shot like
this
what do you think well what do you know
you got a line on a ship
yeah no guy he's the best smuggler
around I heard a story about you I was
wondering if it's true everything you've
heard about me it's true l-3 let's go
with a mean man's face with these guys
[Music]
if you come with us you're in this life
for good might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice
we assume everyone will betray you and
you will never be disappointed I got a
really good feeling about this
when do you know how to fly a hundred
and ninety years old feel great
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie's we got a
new Star Wars trailer to break down we
finally saw Paul Bettany as character
for the first time he's playing an
original character not someone from the
Canon his name is Dryden Voss not
related to Jedi Master Quinlan boss but
let's break everything down so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos don't
forget there is a giant Star Wars movie
coming out after infinity war we get a
much better shot of Corellia and the
other planets that we visit there's at
least 3 confirmed planets possibly more
but obviously there's the shipyards
occur Elliott you see that Star
Destroyer being built in orbit then you
start to see the crew so to speak come
together so when Woody Harrelson's
character Tobias Beckett is talking
about putting a crew together it's
really Paul Bettany's dryden boss that's
backing that play in while we're dealing
with the world of smuggling of course
they're gonna be doing Kessel run
there's rumor Jabba cameo but I think
it's probably one of the worst kept
secrets in Star Wars like everybody
assumes that if we're gonna see Jabba
the Hutt he's gonna pop up during this
movie somewhere but I don't think he's
gonna be a really major character unless
they've done an amazing job of deceiving
us and for those of you asking about
that weird nose on the Falcon they
basically explained that that's just
part of the cargo hold so that probably
gets jettisoned and it looks more like
the conventional Falcon that you saw
during the original trilogy the really
cool thing about this bounty hunter here
is that we found out it's actually a
female character named in fists nest we
don't know a whole lot about her only
that she's a female character and she's
wearing partial Mandalorian armor I
think it's pretty clear they're trying
to invoke boba fett tones no idea if
he's in the movie but this would also be
a place for him to cameo so don't be
surprised if he pops up along with Jabba
the Hutt we finally get some more dialog
from land oh I love this card game here
they're obviously playing soo bahk
that's what they meant to imply this
might not be the game where he actually
wins the Falcon it might be one of the
games that they play but Emilia Clarke's
Keira character has that voice over
where she's just sort of talking to him
and they cut it with all this footage
what are you looking for he pushes all
of his chips in like that's going to be
the hand where he wins the Falcon or
something else and then they actually
cut to the Falcon so most of you
probably pick up on the joke that
whatever sexual chemistry they have will
be overshadowed with Han Solo sexual
chemistry with the Falcon itself like
that says one true
before Leia came along but if it wasn't
clear she pops up at all these scenes in
the club where you see Paul Bettany's
character she's working for him so there
are a lot of intermediaries I don't know
how big a part of the film he is because
he wasn't on set for that long
and they brought him on during the
reshoots the original actor playing the
character couldn't come back so they're
like okay we'll get Paul Bettany big
upgrade they're pulling a heist they
hire him to be the pilot but obviously
the movie is also the transition of Han
Solo getting the Falcon from Lando
Calrissian so most of the shots we see
early in the trailer are with Lando like
him sitting in the back seat then when
they're in the middle of this giant
Maelstrom which might wind up being the
climax of the film with this giant
octopus space looking creature on the
run from the Star Destroyer that might
wind up being the call to action for him
I think it's just a question of when he
plays that game of soo bahk to actually
win it when it physically becomes his
that might not be till the very end of
the film like okay one more hand but
obviously Tobias Beckett's character has
that voice over where he says don't
trust anyone then you'll never be
disappointed but obviously he has
Chewbacca so I wonder how much of his
time in the apear allah Kadim ii they
cut into the film because of all the
reshoots is kind of hard to tell what
parts of the film they rearranged and
what stuff they completely changed so
they're basically telling his entire
life story but a lot of that early stuff
is gonna get condensed like he joins the
Academy gets kicked out I don't know if
they've changed the Canon for how he
meets Chewbacca
because essentially Wookiee slave labor
was used to build the Death Star he went
AWOL rescuing Chewbacca that was the
beginning of his life as a smuggler so
there might be a slightly different
version of that in here but the whole
idea of the story of him helping
Chewbacca and rescuing him is showing
that he is a good character at heart
even though he does very terrible things
like a really good example is the
star-lord character and guardians of the
galaxy very clearly written to be the
Han Solo of the Marvel Universe good
your friend is quite a mercenary I
wonder if he really cares about anything
or anybody sandy Newton's just another
badass character named valve that gets
tied up in their crew if you're not Big
West world fans that show is actually
premiering on HBO later sandy Newton is
one of the main actors she's pretty
fantastic on it so I would recommend
checking it out if you haven't seen a
lot of her stuff love the way they used
to back on the trailer - what do you
think of this Chewie just shakes his
head like nope not having it nope
even though the structure looks like it
was built by wookies I don't think
they're on Kashuk here I think they're
on another planet this is just where
Lando hangs out most of the time look at
all these creatures - that's probably
one of the other best things about Star
Wars that was one of the big bummers of
force awakens is they had their cantina
scene in most of the creatures that they
created for that you didn't really see
unless you watched the bonus features
speaking of bonds though l3d we don't
know a whole lot about her other than
she's like the sassy k2s oh of the film
she seems more like Lando's companion
based on the way he treats her rather
than a servant so I think a pretty easy
prediction to make because we don't know
where she is in present day like you've
never heard of her before this movie is
that she's one of those characters that
they make you love then they wind up
killing her off but for those of you
asking about the dice like there's this
running Easter egg of the dice that you
go all the way back to the original
trilogy the reason why he used the dice
to win the subak game is is because in
this version I believe it's a special
version of soo bahk that's played with
dice rather than the old way wonder how
long the Falcon stays clean though like
see these white walls
how long before everything started to
oxidize and it turned this nice shade of
brown you know obviously we get a bunch
of gratuitous shots of the Falcon
because if you were ever going to treat
a ship like an actual character in a
film Han Solo's Millenium Falcon would
be that character in his own spin-off
movie I think what will happen is is the
movie will wind up being fine like
people are worried about it I think
it'll be okay and it will just prove how
good Ron Howard is at putting a movie
together imagine how good you have to be
as a director to turn a really good film
in amidst all those challenges from a
story standpoint the movie is a pretty
easy pitch like you learn all about Han
Solo's backstory where he came from why
he became the person he became and why
he does the things that he does you see
sort of that roguish attitude where he's
not totally a villain but he's not
totally a good guy so he gets to have
all the fun and be a hero at the same
time that is why he's one of the
coolest characters in the history of
Star Wars but just let me know what you
think of this based on this trailer so
far it's just a reminder that infinity
war is on their press tour now so
there's gonna be a lot of stuff for that
coming really soon
then Deadpool then this - so everything
in the next month or two is are gonna be
really crazy so leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below but
I wouldn't be surprised if we start to
find out a little bit more about what's
going on with episode 9 as this movie
hits theaters but click here for that
other Han Solo trailer and click here
for brand new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight